look who's here it's me it's Colleen are
you going to my Colleen heavens sure
bangs on the day I'm so excited to be
shooting this video with you because I
think that you're an expert in this area
and the area is family it's such a huge
compliment all you're welcome
and your sister is directly to the right
having a great time is whoa that was
Hannah's impression is now becoming
holiday season what is it actually
considered the start of holiday season
it depends on how to pressed you are
because I don't know seasons come and go
but family is forever
and so during the holiday season you
have to spend time with your family so I
asked you guys on Facebook if you needed
any advice on how to be around your
family during the holiday and we're
gonna help you out
ice book that's so mom of you I know I
felt like it's all in the theme how to
convince your family you love the food
they made for you and the gifts they
give you that's really hard
gifts are easier than food because all
you to do is say thank you giving gifts
is literally just the moment of
intersection a myth that's all the
family member wants is that moment yeah
I know what you can do for the food okay
you make it a challenge is if it's about
the views you'll work harder to get it
down you work I gotta get those views
gotta win this challenge
grandma's cranberry sauce challenge
think about your family as people with
the potential to subscribe to you yeah
I'm really gonna make them like you I
naturally and unfortunately attract
children and kids are disgusting and
annoying
how do I not have them want to be
constantly hugging me or holding my
hands oh no when you first started
reading that I thought I was going in
another direction you love children I
love children
we have varying opinions I love children
I enjoy children to climb in like can i
why well actually know it that's not
true
I enjoy the children in my family there
are children that I kind of want to
punch in the face a little bit yeah just
just a little bit just like kinda hard
but I mean I need a mix is like if they
went to their parents and told right
there'd be no proof you know what I mean
oh my gosh it'll scar let's say you're
having an off day with the kids in your
family that you normally like how do you
convince yourself to get along with them
you punch them just and now skew
suggestions to relatively fairly new for
handles are always good
oh that's a great idea I have this new
theory to every holiday season I'm just
gonna by numerous varying amounts of
American Express gift cards just found
them with me at all times
you know what I've done in the past
uh-huh is I've gone to family events and
been like you know we should do is I get
my party and I'll be like we should do a
white elephant so just bring one camped
and then you can just get like a gumball
machine that was $10 to CBS yes the best
gift that you've ever gotten from a
family member
oh I don't know I went to Rachel I hated
her when she was born the best gift I
don't know what's the best gift you've
received from a family member oh God
attention oh yeah that is the best gift
anyone's got me Rachel got me for my
birthday I don't even know what it is
but how to describe it I will never know
but it is like a little statue of Jesus
Christ surfing a wave she got it at the
dollar store I shouldn't ask where'd you
get such a beautiful piece of art
tasting and answering you and your
boyfriend get married there's an evil
Satan so at your body it's really sad
about commitment I hate that though I
was recently married it was I got
married and I thought that would make
that stop I know now people go when are
you having kids
hey guys coming to you from the set of
dirty 30 our new movie go to dirty thong
movie calm to register for updates on
the film hey another great way to ignore
your family I mean interact with your
family in a pleasant way over the
holidays is to throw some headphones in
and listen to an audiobook hey where can
you find an audiobook
at audible.com they have over 150,000
audiobooks on file for you to listen to
it's just as easy I'm doing it right now
you can listen to binge book Tyler with
me book which I highly recommend
it's delicious nutritious easy to digest
and we get a free audiobook download I
got an audible calm slash grace so why
spend time in there over the holidays
when you can spend time out here like
this look how fun this is
download your first audio book on such
great
anyway mafia mafia blah blah so I guess
the concept is to be able to drink
around your family without them knowing
that you're drinking vodka in a water
bottle that was quick
and handle family members talking about
politics when you have very different
viewpoints I think just that there was
some holiday advice for you guys about
handling your family members Thank You
Colleen for giving such great advice of
course anytime and make sure you guys
one subscribe to our channel if you're
not already and to go check out the
video that we showed over there we're
gonna have under our heads
another great way to get out of
conversations with relatives at holidays
I don't know I also like I also like
getting really close to them and
whispering something that will scare
them and then like walk like you know
something like we're just you're going
to die you know